is
[Music]
um
so
[Music]
hi good afternoon or good evening how
are you guys doing today
good thank you for uh joining us here at
the table we're thrilled to have you
here
i'm glad that you're able to make it and
we appreciate those of you who are able
to join us online
uh we appreciate you all as well i do a
couple quick announcements well maybe
not too quick
so so i do have one announcement that i
need to go into some grand details
it's actually really good it's kind of a
fun and i don't want to miss any of
these great details so i'm
actually going to read this one um so
this is about that we're going to have a
two day weekend camp for kids going into
kinder through
sixth grade um and these are going to be
like having games and crafts and
bible story and food and other
activities and it's the whole thing is
going to be completely free
more kids the better it's going to be
one of those kinds of situations
um it's going to be from friday from two
to eight
and then from saturday from 10 to four
and it's going to all wrap up on like
the typical you know sunday evening
service and things like that so all of
that stuff is all going to coordinate
together so it's important for your kids
to be there for
all of it um
say it again the end of july i'm sorry i
don't have a date on here
and there's going to be there's going to
be an email
because that's going to have all the
dates for it so it's going to be the
july
30th through august the 1st see
that's super important miss that missed
that in this little detail
anyway um so it's gonna be very much
like a vbs type of situation
uh four nights cramming it into like two
days um
it's gonna be a theme it's gonna be like
camping
um and so it's gonna going to be at the
runsfield home
um she wants to make it very clear that
they're
actually not camping so there's not
that going on so there's going to be
no sleeping outside no overnight
activities at all
wanted to make sure that is crystal
clear um if your children want
a try once again please register online
you can find a link that's going to be
on facebook
or if you want to leave an email as well
you can there's a there's a place where
you can email there's a link
an email that's going to come with a
link so make sure you sign up follow up
with that
let's see there's more details to come
what's really super important though
this is probably one of the most
important things
is that they can't do this without
volunteers to make sure that this is
going to run successfully and everything
like that so
if you want to spend a couple days if
you love children
which who doesn't i mean kids are a lot
of fun
there's going to be a there is a sign up
sheet in the very back
um so this is going to be important just
to kind of sign up
um love for teens to come helpers is too
um and that's basically it so that's
that's the gist of that
it's very short um
details i only got one detail wrong so
i'm doing i think i'm doing good
uh so the next next uh next announcement
we are doing like a
baptism uh party that's going to be on
sunday august the
8th so this is actually really kind of
neat because it's our first baptism that
we're doing here at the table
um it's going to be also at the
rensselate house
um you know brett's already emailed some
deep some of the details um but
food swimming uh yard games um all kinds
of things like that but if you're
interested in being
uh baptized please visit with brett um
and you know make sure you get all the
details for that and there's gonna be a
baptism class as
well so
i think i went through all that anyway
so i'm gonna do a quick prayer and then
we'll get started
with uh worship lord thank you so much
um for bringing us all together thank
you for this time this opportunity
that we can connect with each other
and just spend time at your feet
learning more about your son and i pray
that you just reach into our hearts our
minds and prepare us for the things that
you want us to hear
in christ i pray amen
thank you sir
all right if you guys want to stand with
us we're going to start this service out
a little acapella
so please join in and if it is your
first time with us tonight
you are welcome in this place just as
you are
um and your voice is welcome in this
place
so i know singing out loud can sometimes
be a little intimidating but i promise
you
you're not going to hit any notes that
we haven't already hit up here in
practice
so just just to relieve the pressure
we've already hit
all the bad ones so so just you know
this is a safe
space um we're gonna go ahead and get
started
this one's called oh how i need you and
i really wanted to say
real quick um i was like i thought we
were about to start again
um we're doing this deconstruction
series and this has been one of my
favorite songs to come back
to any time that i am trying to
wrestle through a new uh you know a new
issue or maybe a verse or an old way of
thinking or a theology that's being
passed down
i have loved that this song welcomes the
questions and says that god is right
there
right in the midst of those questions
he's not pushing them away he's not
afraid of them
they are welcome and that's sometimes
right where we find him
so let's just enter in with that spirit
all right of bringing it all
all our stuff all right now we can
actually start
lord i find you
in the seeking
in the doubt
[Music]
is
oh
oh how i need
one two three four
[Music]
and to know oh
before your
[Music]
you oh
ah
sing light my glorious life i will go
where you shine break the dawn crack the
skies
[Music]
sing that again
make the way right before me in your
life
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
beautiful thank you guys
we're gonna go into our prayers of the
people
and you may have done this with us
before so you might know the drill but
if not
it's a tradition that we're borrowing
from
many years back in christian history and
it's a time for all of us to bring the
things that we are carrying on our
hearts our concerns our worries
um people especially the people that are
on your heart tonight it's a time for us
to share them together
and hold them up before god believing
that he's listening
he is paying attention to the things
that we're carrying and he wants to
shoulder those with us
he wants to intentionally care for us in
that way and care for them and those
situations that are going on so i'm
going to read through
a short prayer and at the end of each
line there's going to be words on the
screen in red if you guys want to read
that
phrase we pray to you together with me
and then when i get to the end of the
prayer i'll open it up for a time for
you to speak
out that person's name or that situation
that's on your heart
and if you're listening online feel free
to comment
in the comment section and someone will
be
checking those and and shouting them out
i don't see karen right now but
um i don't know if brett might be
tracking that and he'll share them with
us as we go through
and then i'll wrap it up with a short
prayer at the end so
i just invite you guys to join and share
the things the people that you are
carrying tonight
and i'm gonna
[Music]
jesus for the city of saxi texas
and for every city and community and all
of those who live in them
we pray to you for the good earth that
you have given us
and the wisdom and the will to conserve
it
we pray to you for those who travel on
land
sea or air we pray to you
for the old and the sick for the widow
and the orphan
for the injured and suffering we pray
to you for the poor
and the oppressed the unemployed
and the destitute for prisoners and
captives
and for all who remember and care for
them
we pray to you lord we know that you
love us
and that you hear us and so we lift
these names and situations
up to you
[Music]
charlie
sarah
[Music]
for these names and moments that we have
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light healing and hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
bring your worry grief and pain
every cause you have for shame
it all down
lay it all down
and win your cares i buried you
and there's nothing left to do
laid it all down
we laid it all down at the feet of
jesus
[Music]
you carried on but your heart was tired
you feared the worst and felt the fire
laid it all down
[Music]
you're filled with all those anxious
thoughts
and all your devils became your gods
laid all down
lay it all down at the feet of
[Music]
jesus jesus
lay it all down lay it all down lay it
all down lay it all
down
[Music]
laid
jesus
at the feet of jesus
[Music]
there are memories
and there's nothing here that can ease
the pain
laid it all down
laid all down at the feet of
jesus
[Music]
[Applause]
at the feet of jesus
[Music]
lay it all down lay it all down lay it
all down
lay it
[Music]
jesus
at the feet of jesus
and i've searched the world
but it couldn't fill me
[Music]
and man's empty graves and treasures of
faith
are never enough
then you came
and you pull me back together
and every desire is now satisfied
here in your love
oh there's nothing
better than you oh there's nothing
nothing is better than you
and i'm not afraid
[Music]
to show you my weakness
my failures and flies lord you've seen
it all and you still call me friend
[Music]
cause the god of the mountain
is the god of the valley
and there's not a place and mercy
and grace would again
come on no there's nothing
better than you oh there's nothing
better than you know there's nothing
there's nothing is better than you
oh lord there's nothing
better than you know there's nothing
better than you oh there's nothing
nothing is better than you
[Music]
sing this with me
you turn morning to dancing
[Music]
you turn green in the ashes
you turn shame into glory
you're the only one who can
you turn graves into gardens
you turn bones into armies
you turn seas into highways
you're the only one who
cares you turn morning to dancing
you get beauty for ashes
[Music]
you turn shame into glory
you're the only one who
can here we go you turn
graves into gardens
[Music]
you turn bones into armies
you turn seas into highways
you're the only one
[Applause]
you're the only one who
cares
when there's nothing
better than you oh there's nothing
put your hands together better than you
oh there's nothing
[Music]
nothing is better than you
yeah no
there's nothing better than you
oh there's nothing
better than you oh there's nothing
nothing is better than you let's sing
that one more time
oh there's nothing
better than you oh there's nothing
nothing is better
[Music]
[Applause]
yes god we lift up your name and say
thank you
thank you for being a god who turns our
darkest
worst moments into things that we can
grow from
into things that can bring life and
light and hope to others god
thank you for being a redeeming god
a god who doesn't see us as shameful but
as beautiful
as a reflection of who you are
god you look at us and you see your
image
god would we continue to reflect it
in our relationships in our homes at
work
at school would we reflect your image
god
would we see the fingerprints of jesus
all over our life
and would we see them in each other
we love you and we thank you for who you
are and what you're doing in our
community and we just
ask that you would continue it god make
us aware of where you're moving and help
us
to follow you
open our hearts continue to speak to us
and it's in your name we pray all these
things
amen thank you guys so much for
worshiping with us and we're going to go
ahead and continue that as brett comes
to speak
turn around to the people around you and
say hello real quick give a
quick shout out to someone you might not
have seen
well good evening everyone super good to
be with you
thanks for um joining us
grace and peace man it's an another
sunday
it's um it's just man what a privilege
to just be with you all um
week after week i love um the
consistency
of the rhythm of worshiping god once a
week and just
man it's so it's so good just good to be
with you all so
i want to welcome all of you um but
including those joining
us online we love you lots and
anyone here who's new and kind of
plugging in i'm so glad that you're
um here and joining us so it's uh yeah
wonderful to have you
so we are in let's see it's part two uh
in our series
uh titled deconstruction um finding god
again and um i should name that while
am i hearing a little bit of kind of
fuzz are y'all hearing that
am i okay it's not bad all right i'll
keep going um
so i want to mention that um while
deconstruction
kind of has like a more academic meaning
for anyone who is a philosopher nerd
and you are into post-modern philosophy
then you know
it kind of has like a specific meaning
it kind of comes from jacques darada
and there's like a whole wing of thought
that's like doing things
with deconstruction and um while there
is a kind of connection
between what we're talking about in this
series and that
um it's not quite the same thing and so
i want to name
um just on the off chance there's like
two people who are really bugged
that i seem to not be talking a lot
about jacques darda and
post-modern philosophy i'm definitely
i'm using it in
more the sense that it has come to mean
in the broader church
um and and really deconstruction it kind
of started there in that world and kind
of jumped out of the academy and then
kind of has become you know kind of what
am i trying to say
it has gone mainstream in the church and
really here what it tends to mean um is
kind of a season of wrestling a season
of
question asking a season of kind of
really questioning
inherited beliefs and theologies
and um and the way even we talked about
it last week was
the idea of kind of um almost having to
process our church
of origin in the same way you have a
family of origin uh
many of us have a church of origin or um
some place that you start to pick up
ideas and theologies about god
and the world and yourself and christ
and you know and and some of what
deconstruction
is kind of a working through that and
realizing oh well not all of that was
um actually helpful um even some certain
ideas might have been really destructive
uh so that's kind of what this series is
about is really processing that
not a deep dive into um deridian
philosophy or something so
um so i should uh i want to start here
with uh
our passage which is matthew chapter 28
verses 16 through 20.
if you've got your bible you can read
along or of course
follow um on the screen so
matthew 28 verses 16-20 then the 11
disciples
went to galilee to the mountain where
jesus had told them to go
and when they saw him they worshipped
him but some doubted
then jesus came to them and said all
authority in heaven
and on earth has been given to me
therefore go
and make disciples of all nations
baptizing them in the name of the father
and of the son
and of the holy spirit and teaching them
to obey
everything i have commanded you and
surely i am with you
always to the very end of the age
so i um i'm kind of one of
uh the last generation that got to do
something very significant
this is sort of a fading thing in the
culture
i when i was young about like say around
age 7 8
9 10 i got to play outside
without my parents watching me
i know you're thinking like what how how
are you alive right now
i mean just the grace of god i guess i
don't know um it is it's kind of
it's fascinating the culture you know
how things kind of shift and change over
time
um and looking back i mean there was a
lot of good uh
from that i mean honestly i had a lot of
fun um there were a few things that we
did that looking back i'm kind of
yeah that was questionable some parental
supervision might have been wise
and um one of those those things
is i still have these these memories of
i mean i was young
man maybe even like six i don't know but
i was just riding around my neighborhood
you know my bicycle
and we were playing cops and robbers
this was kind of the game you know kids
play maybe you played it
um and it was just a bicycle game you
know you're going around trying to like
tag people
or you know whatever and so what i have
this distinct memory
of is us playing this game but we
figured out that a really good way to
get people or stop them in their tracks
was to either
throw or jam sticks
into the spokes of a bicycle tire did
anyone do this or was this just me
rollins dude yes kirby did um yeah it
was
i mean looking back at this question i
really literally i have memories of me
i mean i both sinned against others and
i would end against in this way like
i have memories of riding my bicycle
around the stick in my hand throwing it
like throwing trying and a lot of times
you know nine out of 10 times you'd miss
not always though um but i also have the
memory of me riding my bicycle and all
of a sudden someone jumps out from
behind
you know the fence and it's like ah and
they jab it in and y'all i mean it's
remarkable how quickly a tire will just
i mean you get that you know a stick
strong enough it just and i have this
memory
of me just kind of floating like like a
bird just no
now i don't associate this with
tremendous pain which
i think must mean i must have blended in
the grass i don't know but
um yeah oh childhood
um now i bring this up because what's
interesting about this passage
is it occurs to me that matthew jams
a stick right into the spokes
of of his remarkable amazing story
um so this i mean the passage we just
read it's basically it's the
end of the book of matthew these are
literally we just read the final words
that's it verse 20.
that's it that's how it ends so he's
just written this like magnum opus of
like
the story of christ and you know it's 28
chapters and
i mean and i mean it's the stirring
conclusion
right it's like the high point here they
are jesus told them where to be i'm
going to be on this mountain
in galilee they get there they they see
him um you know they worship him
um and here's what's so interesting
though
um is here's what i think it should say
this is how i think matthew should have
done it
um if it were me um it would have gone
something like this um
when they saw him they worshipped him
and then jesus came to them and said all
authority in heaven and
on earth has been given to me and so on
and so forth i can go into his big
speech
and yet what happens is
not that did you catch the line did you
catch those all right so there's this
this line where
here he is right the disciples are there
they see him it says
um they they gather around him they
worship him
[Music]
but what was the line but some what did
you catch it
doubted
i'm fascinated by this like why
why would he put that in there i mean
this is you know if you're trying to
persuade people to believe
and you know this is like your whole
story and here we are the closing
sentences
and they're there and they worshipped
yeah but some people had some you know
questions in the back of their mind
um i'm i'm just fascinated by this
passage um
i love it so tonight i want to give you
um
three um kind of um myths about doubt
last week we just touched on doubt it
was sort of implicit in the message but
i really wanted to make it explicit i
really wanted to unpack this idea of
doubt and because it's been kind of
stigmatized in the church a lot
you know i think you think of you know
christianity as the people of faith
right and so we tend to think well
what's the opposite of faith
well doubt so faith is good well doubt
is like
right and there's been a lot of stigma
around a lot of even shame
you know like don't bring that up don't
don't say that your doubts are not
welcome here um and so i want to help us
kind of move beyond some of that because
i think actually matthew would probably
disagree
so here's um three myths about
doubt that i think this passage dispels
myth number one if you're note taker you
can
you can jot this down myth number one
only
bad christians doubt in the scare quotes
is bad for those listening on the uh on
the podcast later
only bad christians doubt um you know
for some reason
every time i had read this text
previously i it could be because another
gospel tells the story slightly
differently i'm not sure
but i always just assumed that there was
like a
broader or multiple groups of people
here
i thought it was like the disciples and
some other folks and so when it said you
know they worshipped him
i my brain just filled in
well that's the disciples the 11 right
the 11 disciples because um judas
is no longer with him so not 12. now
it's 11. all right so i assume it was
the 11
and then you have some you know the
other maybe the second-class
christians or something you know the
riff-raff are kind of there and they're
like we're not sure
um but actually uh no if
let's read it again verse 16 then the 11
disciples
went to galilee to the mountain where
jesus had told them to go
and when they saw him they worshipped
him
but some doubted not remarkable that i
mean
these are some of jesus closest friends
these were folks who at least from a
distance
had um witnessed some of the crucifixion
they had been there um soon after jesus
had appeared to them in his resurrection
i mean they're like they got the front
row
you know seats to this to this whole
thing and yet
um they doubted now i'm uh
i am kind of i have another kind of
question or i think that's in the back
of my mind
i'm sort of speculating here but um i do
wonder
how did matthew know that
and it's possible they shared afterwards
but my hunch is
i mean would someone come up to matthew
like hey i heard you're writing that
book what did you call it a god he's
like a gospel oh that's right you're
writing that gospel thing um
you know maybe you should know that when
everyone was there remember that moment
where jesus was about to ascend to
heaven and
everyone's worshiping him just so you
know i was totally not sure
um like i'm my guess is no one came up
to him and just was like
on the dl don't say my name but you
should put that in there
um i might and so here's i'm guessing
that didn't happen
um now here's what's interesting matthew
was one of the 11 who was there
which gets me to thinking was it him
like in other words is that how he knew
that
they were there and they saw him and
they worshipped him and yes there was
faith in that moment like it was
real and yet at the same time
but some doubted um again i'm
reading that that's not like explicitly
there but it could be like maybe that's
how he
knew because he was there
and in the back of his mind he was like
oh my gosh
is this real um
all right so that's the first myth only
bad christians doubt because i
man i don't think um the disciples i
don't think matthew i don't think
regardless whether it was matthew or
some others
they weren't bad christians like these
were people who went on to
transform the world in powerful ways
i mean nearly all of them died a
martyr's death
um so these weren't bad kurt like these
were folks
these were true believers and yet they
had their doubts too
fascinating um all right second second
myth
uh is this idea that perfect evidence
drives away all doubts i think this is
probably
one of the hardest lessons for us to
learn
especially if you're of a particularly
intellectual bent
where you're like you want to figure it
out you know and
get all the eyes dotted and t's crossed
and like figure out your reasons and
your arguments
and you know get it all clear um
those of us who who want to really uh
sort of arrive
at the mythical land of certainty
anyone ever want to arrive at certainty
i do
um and it's such a it's such a powerful
temptation
for us um but
you know but here's the thing i mean if
there was ever a group
of christians who were gathered
in it a writer should have been able to
say about them
there they were and they saw him and
they
worshipped him and not one no
not even one had a doubt
for their eyes had seen the glory of the
coming of the lord
i mean if there's ever a group of people
that a writer should have been able to
say those words
uh it should have been these people i
mean they're like
right there like they're like i said
they're front row seats to the whole
thing i mean his whole
and not even just the crucifixion
resurrection all that but like three
years before they'd seen every miracle
every jaw on the floor kind of moment
like oh my gosh
who he seems like much more than a man i
mean clearly he's a man
but there's like something else going on
here i mean
they'd seen it all and and yet
um even they had these this moment of
like oh my gosh
now we might kind of question this
sounds crazy though like
they they were bad christians because i
mean if i that were me i wouldn't have
doubts i think here's the
the thing um the truth is
no matter what we experience no matter
what we see i mean because some of us
think if jesus would just show up in my
room
and be like hello i am jesus we're like
now i believe you know but here's the
thing i mean
let's say that happens and then you
can't sleep for hours
but eventually you drift off to sleep
you wake up the next morning
and you know he's gone and you're like
what was that
did i dream that i'm not really sure
was i hallucinating maybe i might be
having a psychotic break i mean
right can you just go down the road of
like
and i'm seeing it with our eyes hearing
it with our ears like something that
comes in through our senses
i mean the truth is we're just human
beings we aren't we don't have you know
we're not omnipotent all-knowing all
seen we're not god
and so we don't have that god's eye view
which means
um there is always room for doubt no in
regards and this is true
regardless of even faith i mean this
isn't just a problem of like well
this is a problem with christianity you
know it requires faith but but i'm
different i want to believe things that
don't require faith like sorry friend
everything requires some faith because
you got to make some assumptions about
the world you got
a community of people i mean even i
might get into this um later
in a series do a sermon on science and
faith and it's interesting that even
science there's still
an element of faith because i mean you
can't literally be the one to run
every experiment you have to trust
people like did you do that right you
know there's
there's still a community and um
and even then you can make assumptions
you can miss something you can
misinterpret i mean there's
right in other words um as human beings
we just we
never arrive at the mythical land we're
just
which by the way doesn't mean i don't
think that we just have to walk around
like well i just don't know
anything ever you know like this sort of
perpetual
um uh doubt i don't think you have to
get kind of in that cynic mode
but it but it does mean there there is
always an element of
um look i have my thoughts i have my
reasons i have my own
um experiences i'm kind of bringing all
that to the table
but i'm but no i'm not not certain
in that in that way um i remember in my
own
kind of background and story there was a
point where i always had so many
questions about
god and christian faith and all that i
shared a little bit of this last week
and i was just i had plenty of doubts
and honestly i got really sick of having
doubts about christian faith so i
finally reached a point where i was like
you know what i think i'm just done
like i still kind of believe in god like
i think it makes sense
god is there or something but in terms
of christianity and all its
particularity
you know all the particulars all the
doctrines i just i can't do this i can't
because i just don't know
and so oh again i just got sick of it so
i was like you know i think i'm done i'm
just not a christian anymore
uh and this was great for like a week
because i was like oh it felt so good
to finally be kind of certain again like
ah yes
pesky doubts you know i don't believe
such things you know
um and then a week goes by and then two
and then three and then slowly the doubt
started to creep back in
only now it was in the reverse direction
i started to doubt my doubt
i started be like oh gosh but wait what
if it's true
what if christ really did rise from the
dead what if
oh my oh my gosh what if i really will
be called to account on judgement day or
i don't know all these kind of you know
ideas and things and all of a sudden i
found myself
now what is this an example of i
realized in this moment
oh so this is what it is to be a human
being
no matter what path you go down um like
um and still i have a deep interest in
buddhism um
but but there was a point where i
thought maybe that's more my path you
know but even there i
realized there was still this faith you
know like this
guy in the buddha who was like had this
enlightenment experience and so i'm
going to meditate for like 20 000 hours
and maybe experience it
how do i know what if i solve for not
what if it's all just i mean
can you see how no matter what road you
go down
um you never you never arrive so this is
this idea of perfect evidence drives
away all doubt i just yeah
not happening um c.s lewis said this
faith
is the art of holding on to things that
your reason
has once accepted in spite of your
changing
moods
i like that um because it is it's very
easy
to be kind of swept up with um or for
one or just our own
kind of swings and seasons and you know
bad things happened in this season of my
life so
now it's okay with god you know but then
later good things
and i'm like okay i'm back i'm back you
know um or people around me
are believing things so i'm like okay
yes yes yes and then i get in a new
community and they don't believe the
sentence so i'm like
okay no never mind no this is what we
believe we don't yeah we're out no no
we're out on this and then
like okay no we're in we're back you can
see how
life can just kind of push you around
um and this isn't uh well i like that he
names
uh things that your reason has once
accepted because what i'm not trying to
give here is this idea of just like well
just feel it out man and just
believe whatever you want because i mean
who knows anything
um there is i think you still need to
use your mind right
even the bible talks about this love god
with all your mind so there
there is i think the mind matters
reasons matter
evidence and you know things making
sense to you
that matters um
but at the same time there is that
faith is kind of what keeps you grounded
in the midst of those waves of life and
culture and people and
family and you know all the drama and
boy you can just get
bullied you know um all right so that's
um that's number two number three
myth number three is the idea that doubt
and worship
cannot coexist
another assumption i made when i'd read
this text previously
was i once i realized it was the
disciples then i made
another kind of leap which was okay so
there's two groups among the disciples
there were the true you know faithful
disciples the worshiping disciples and
then there were some other
people but again like read
read the text uh verse 17 when they
and we know previously that's the 11
when they saw him
they worshipped him but some doubted
in other words i don't think it was that
there was one group who's kind of like
the true you know and they're there with
their hands raised just praying the lord
and then you know a few other disciples
are kind of off to the side like
arms folded you know like eye rolling
that's not the image you get
instead what you get is they were there
they saw him
they worshipped him and then some even
in the midst of their
doubt were worshipping too
um i think this matters because in
church kind of settings
often um there's a pressure you know to
um to just just believe you know just
believe just have faith you know don't
push away those doubts run
run from them they're of the devil or
something you know that's just the
demons you're tricking you or whatever
um and and it's it's there's almost this
mentality of
you know you got to do that so that you
can worship
you know you got to get rid of those
pesky doubts so that you can pray
you've you've got to gotta push back
so that you can you know be holy or
something um
and and i think that's just not the
picture you get in the bible and it's
certainly not the picture you get in
this
passage instead it almost seems like
we're invited um we might say it like
this
in the midst of my doubt i'm invited to
worship
in the midst of them i'm invited to
um my often quoted
theodor dostoyevsky every fourth sermon
at least
i quote dostoyevsky um
and he was someone who uh a novelist a
russian novelist who
really wrestled with faith and doubt and
questions and
kind of uh i mean it was really it's
quite profound his
his novels um and so at the towards the
end of his life and if you've read his
books you know like this is really true
um because he doesn't poke fun at
atheism he it's he takes it
very seriously um and really he doesn't
straw man
yet he steel-man's it i mean some of his
arguments he makes probably some of the
most powerful arguments in favor of
atheism in his novels
that i've ever read even though he
wasn't
one um and he took it dead serious
but towards the end of his life 1881 he
he wrote this
he said it is not as a child that i
believe in christ
and confess him my hosanna has passed
through
a great crucible that means like a trial
uh oppressing a pressure
of doubt
and i i love the way that he names that
his
his hosanna that means like his worship
um was not
derailed by his doubts was not
silenced by his doubts but it was
actually it
it purified in in
um made it more beautiful
it more mature
and so tonight we are going to
be engaging in communion and the
invitation
um to you of course there's no pressure
to engage if you're like i don't want to
no problem
no pressure um but if you've
you're sitting there and um
you wonder like i don't know if i can
engage something like this like i don't
know if i can really
you know trust god or worship god i
don't know if i can engage
i think the beautiful part about um
the christian faith and the invitation
from christ
is for us to bring our doubts with us to
the table
of the lord and isn't it lovely that in
this passage
does jesus berate the disciples
does he you know give them trouble
because some of you not all of you are
really believing in no he just
he just he commissions them all he sends
them all
um and that's the beautiful thing about
our faith in this moment is that christ
just welcomes us
just right right where we're at so i
know that
not everyone is familiar with the
practice of communion so this goes back
um many thousands of years right to um
the very beginning
of christian faith it was the moment um
when the night jesus was betrayed
he had one final meal with his disciples
and
during that meal he stood up and he held
up a loaf of bread
and then he broke it and he said this is
my body referring of course to the
crucifixion to come the next day
and then he held up a cup of wine and he
said this
this is my blood whenever you eat this
bread
whenever you drink this cup remember me
remember me and so for 2000 years
christians have
come to the table of the lord to
remember
again who god is who christ
is in the life of love and
joy and forgiveness and goodness and
faith
that he he calls us to so that's what
this time that's what this time is about
and um i want to mention for those who
are
joining us online if you have like some
bread or
any like grape juice or wine or
something you know there
in your house feel free we'd love for
you to join us and
if you don't feel fancy that's okay
because tonight we had a little snafu a
little mix up with
with um uh we'll just go into it we just
had an issue where we don't have our
normal communion cups
so we got fancy dixie cups for communion
tonight
um so uh and in just a moment
um eric and michael are gonna come
forward they're gonna serve you
communion
um but we're just gonna form kind of one
line right here down the middle
and um they'll hand you a piece of bread
and then um you can just go by
and grab a cup and then at that time you
can just take it immediately
um or you can return to your seat and
partake
and yeah that's kind of how this will go
um
we also do have gluten free bread for
anyone who needs that it'll stay there
on the table on the end
so um all right
last we practice what's called an open
table here
meaning as i said earlier if you want to
participate in communion
you are welcome i don't know if i have
all the right beliefs well you're
welcome to partake
if if you have enough faith to say god
if you're there i want to connect with
you
christ if you're present i want to know
you that's you just
start there you just you just join um
this is the lord's table it's not ours
we don't feel the need to like
police his table you know um
so let me go ahead and welcome you to
the table with this
this is a a christian a celtic
invitation and it goes like this
this is the table not of the church
but of the lord and it's made ready for
those who love him
and for those who want to love him more
so come
you who have much faith and you who have
little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow and you who
have failed
because it's the lord who invites you
and it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him
here come to the table
[Music]
so
i think
[Music]
come all liars come all
shamed come all wealthy
come receive it
to the table clown today
come all broken come
[Music]
come all sinners come old saints
come to the table
from near and far
come from the shadows
come out of the dark
there's room at the table
we've saved you a seat
come to the bank away
come join in
[Music]
from the fringes come to
jesus to the table
full of grace
to the table come and
[Music]
there's no inner circle
come let down your guide
you're never stranger
just come as you are
[Music]
love
accepted
[Music]
come now
prepared
the party is waiting
there's more still to fear
[Music]
is
as a kingdom of peace
as
[Music]
thank you for making room for each one
of us thank you for calling each one of
us
for seeing us unique and beautiful and
loved
for continuing to write our story
may we find you in our confidence and in
a doubts
and may we see your fingerprints all
over the map
[Music]
god don't let us discount what you're
doing
don't let us discount ourselves god
even in our disbelief
it's in your name we pray amen
[Music]
uh thank you so much for joining us here
tonight
if you find yourself in need of prayer
i would be happy to pray with you if you
want to come up i would love to be able
to do that
for you this time also if
you're a visitor you're new to the table
um there are some welcome cards
we would like to be able just to know
who you are uh
say thanks for joining us and just uh
reach out to you
um so there's some welcome cards outside
i'm just gonna make sure you see those
on off
there's a small little table outside in
the hallway and then also
um if you would like to support us
financially
uh you can also do that there's a little
written box also outside
where you can do that and also if you uh
would like to do that online there's a
place where there's a website at the
very top corner of our website
thetabletx.org
there's a place to give um there as well
uh those of you who are online
if you want to fill out at the there's a
place where you can contact us for
either prayer or support we will
be able to do that there and also to be
able to check out online first to give
as well
um just quick to the two announcements
that i
kind of mentioned at the beginning don't
forget about the summer rama that's
going to be happening here in the next
few weeks and
also uh the baptism uh ceremony this our
service that we're gonna be doing also
uh
one last thing i just want to send you
out with it's just this quick
blessing may the lord bless and keep you
may the lord make his face shine i mean
be gracious to you
towards you may the lord turn his face
towards you and give
you peace thank you have a great evening
sorry
you